today I want to talk about recording
your processes greetings everybody from
San Francisco I am here in California as
a mix of business and personal I went to
interview somebody Christopher Gavigan
from the honest company for my book an
entrepreneur have a great tremendous
amount of respect for and I'm honored
that is going to be in the book and I'm
also going to be meeting YouTube
tomorrow which is pretty exciting I was
assigned a channel manager and he said
that my channel is one of the most
innovative he's ever seen which is
highly flattering and very cool and so
I'm going to meet with him tomorrow and
they were just outside San Francisco at
same time here with with my wife and
exploring California having some fun
today's message is about recording your
processes and I think one of the biggest
things that you need to do as an
entrepreneur is record your processes so
that it's easy to give to somebody else
and I hate having to do tasks repeatedly
and I automate as much as possible and
when I can't I always delegate it off to
somebody else and the way I usually do
it is i'll do a google hangout and i'll
record my screen and then it's saved as
a unlisted youtube video that i can
share with that person to say here is
how you do XYZ so how that relates to my
books and that's what this series is
about is I have a great helper with me
helping me do the interviews of the book
and recording all the questions and the
answers and I ty he ranges in Portland
and we always do every interview via
google hangout and so she's on the call
but then I also recorded so that we have
all the information ready to go in case
her notes aren't grade we want to go
over another point or the person is
talking too quickly or whatever this
recording of it so that we can refer
back to and over and over and over again
and it's great for me because I can just
focus on the person I'm interviewing and
not worrying about taking notes and
making sure that I get all the like I'm
I'm present i'm in the moment and if
you're so concerned about like writing
everything down to that person saying
then i find that it's harder to stay
present and it's harder to ask great
follow-up questions because often the
best answers actually come from the
follow-up say well that's interesting
how about this and if you're too busy
writing down then you don't always pay
the most attention and give yourself the
mental what's the word free up your
brain power to actually be thinking
about where else you could take this
conversation besides the standard
questions that you wrote down so I find
the super helpful for my book and I
think it could be really helpful for you
guys if you're writing the book but also
in general for your business record your
processes so that it's easy to give off
to somebody else I'm gonna get to a
bunch of questions is late I slept two
and a half hours last night I was
excited about coming here and then I
slept another two hours in the car on
the drive here Nina Nina spelled me for
two hours so I'm starting to crash
though we had a busy day insane friend
but I want to answer your question so a
few came in from the last episode miss
Scotch is back she asked a question how
do you mentally handle success what
things do you do to keep yourself
grounded and stay focused on what is
actually important I'm seeing money
coming for myself now and I know it's
just a beginning but I'm afraid that
when I make the shift from reprints of
sewing I won't be able to handle it i
hope you understand what I mean thank
you for your hard work there's a lot of
people who sabotage themselves who don't
feel like they deserve success who don't
feel like they deserve the money that's
coming to them for me it's interesting
because I've never been about the money
I've always been about the impact and so
when I start quoting companies to do
events or if I'm speaking at a fee I've
now up my speaking for you it's ten
thousand dollars plus travel and
accommodations and all that to get me to
speak in an event and and I don't know I
don't feel like I feel like I'm the same
person I don't feel like I've changed at
all because I don't I've never cared
about the money coming in I don't know
if that may be that may be sound strange
but my goal always has been will this
impact people you know that's what makes
me feel good that's what gets me to be
driven and motivated to want to continue
on like why am I doing this why am I
making this video you know I'm exhausted
I've had very little seat by the full
day in San Francisco you know I want to
relax have a shower good bed wake up get
rich from our YouTube date tomorrow
but I'm here according to the few guys
because I want to help you like it fuels
me it drives me I'm already getting more
excited and have more energy than i had
coming into the room and so i would just
be looking at understanding who you are
and not not having money to find you
like money is not the biggest thing that
you want to get in your life and you
want to make sure that the you know the
money's represent representation
providing value and the more value
provides the more money you're just
going to make and not being driven by
money i think will help keep you
grounded if you start doing things for
the money then you might start to self
sabotage yourself but i think if you're
driven by something else as long as
that's being fulfilled then you'll just
want to do that more and money becomes a
natural byproduct of it next up tamara
great to see you again tamara love
hearing about your team growing exciting
what happens if you don't meet the book
deadline that's an interesting question
one that i hope i don't have to face the
way it's been scheduled as there are
certain milestones so i have to have it
completed by a certain date and then
we're going to launch it by a certain
date they said there is some flexibility
there is some leniency as long as you
see that progress is happening i'm
probably not the typical author I don't
know um you know when I set a goal for
something I tend to get it done before
schedule just kind of knowing me that's
how I like to operate mostly I think it
comes from a fear of letting people down
I don't like letting people down when
people rely on me when I commit to
something I tend to over-deliver because
I'm afraid I'm going to let them down
and so I'm not overly concerned even
though like that deadline is looming and
it's coming up on me quickly and and
we're not ready yet I think the worst
case scenario is that they could cancel
it and say hey you didn't meet our
deadline because that's what we
scheduled in but my my feeling is
they'll be pretty lenient as long as
it's not massively over because they're
used to dealing with that from authors
but my gut is telling me that I'll have
it done on time Pete congrats on 100,000
subscribers looking forward to my video
reaction yeah i'm at 90 something
thousand one hundred thousand coming
soon and I have a special video coming
forward I apologize that the videos
bouncing I'm on a bed so
sorry for that I'm I'll try to keep
still Thank You Pete I appreciate it I'm
super excited mean like the growth has
been tremendous so pumped that we're
getting to a hundred thousand and
looking forward to getting to 1 million
next a jurist I'm so excited about your
book can't wait to really keep up the
good work thank you for all you do thank
you I'm humbled I'm honored I appreciate
the support and having you guys along
with me on that journey is special and
exciting and I'm grateful for you guys T
has growth TV great video Evan I have
two questions can I get a free copy of
the book when it's finished bro come on
man two could you discuss the creating
an outline process for the book do you
have any tips you could share that help
you be more creative or any tips to help
someone who is trying to write a book
and get out of writer's block would love
to hear your thoughts thanks this is a
little bit different for me because I am
NOT writing a fiction book it's a
nonfiction book and so nonfiction comes
from your knowledge right it's coming
from truth and so I'm writing about
experiences that that I've gone through
experiences that I personally have have
gone through in my businesses and then
also that I've helped people with and
how I started off is I try to think kind
of big picture what are the one of three
main things that I want to cover you
know what's the most important what's
the easiest way to get the message
across how do I break this down into
simple steps this is one core concept
and then how do I break that down the
simple steps so those three main
sections and then from there how do I
break each section down into even
simpler steps so that you you know you
might get the first big concept and then
you might not get the next steps on
their own so then it's breaking it down
then make it easy easy easy so I want it
to be so that you understand the
philosophy and then it's also super easy
to implement and this has come as a
result of me helping other people go
through that process as well as doing it
for myself and so I think it's easier in
that once I had that planned out and
scope that which didn't take so long
it's more about actually delivering and
writing the content that's taking the
long time so I think if you are a
nonfiction writer you just have to have
some truth to say right you have to have
a story you have to have results you
have to have some success you have to
have something that's
went out of your head to be able to
share you have wisdom right if you don't
have the wisdom or the processes then
you shouldn't be writing the book if
you're nonfiction if you're writing
fiction you know I don't know if I have
the best advice for that I think a
fiction book is highly creative and so
if I was to write a fiction book I would
try to create a schedule or routine to
get me into creative zone as much as
possible I find a most creative when I
have a shower I find them creative when
I'm outdoors I find I'm creative when
I'm we know it when I'm thinking I often
fiddle with my wedding ring I often kind
of flip it over if somebody gives me a
challenge and I'm I'm thinking and I'm
trying to find a solution I often find
myself playing around so I would try to
do those kinds of things to get me into
the zone I know a lot of people suggests
just sit down and write that doesn't
work for me so I don't know i would i
would have to find i would encourage you
to find what works for you forcing
yourself to sit down and write works
great but for me i would i would if i
had writer's block go take a walk go
talk to somebody go play a game you
don't have a shower do some exercises
you know fiddle with something I often
get my best ideas when I'm not even
trying to think about that that thought
purposely it's like trying to tell
somebody brings to them right now give
me your best creative idea where that's
often not how brainstorming really works
you can't force that creativity ah so
that's my view so yeah I would try to
have a loose schedule and try to give
myself as much freedom and creativity as
possible next up new future builder good
to see your team growing thanks man do
you have any sales and marketing people
as a part of your team and if so what
roles do they play in promoting your
book and do you recommend any software
to help manage and communicate with them
I could go on for a long time about this
i'm not a huge believer in sales people
as a general rule my way of generating
business is to provide insane value to a
demographic which in my case is
entrepreneurs and as a result i get a
lot of interest right people watch my
videos they leave comments they
to my newsletter big brands take notice
and hire me go to create Google Hangouts
with them or Twitter chats I get paid to
speak at events and so I provide a lot
of stuff out there for free and build up
an audience and then I find ways to
capitalize on that whether it might be
selling the book it could be working
with big brands or speaking engagements
or whatever it is but that's my
preferred way to do things because I'm
not a big fan of being sold to in
general I'm not a big fan of people
spamming me on email or on you know my
phone I don't have a phone so you can't
cold call me but you know I'm not a big
fan of cold calling in general you know
if I'm not a big fan of that why would I
then be doing that to other people
didn't make a lot of sense so I have
people who helped me with the marketing
but not on the sales side I guess it'll
have an official salesperson in terms of
software that I use and communication I
usually communicate by email my team all
have me on facebook that's the fastest
way to reach me typically because I have
an open usually during the day when I'm
on when I'm when I'm on the computer
because they don't have a phone nobody
can reach me urgently with with a phone
message or text and I encourage people
not to use unless it's urgent and so we
don't really have a lot of emergencies
so people usually just hit me up on
email and I'm a big believer in trying
to create on no crisis business and I
find email highly effective so I have a
folder that goes that my team goes to my
family goes to my media contacts big
clients my master my members go to this
folder that I check at least once a day
and that's how we communicate pretty
pretty easy and then last one Malik I'm
working on my second YouTube video right
now it's a unique attempt at a video
resume I'm looking to target very
specific employers and make a strong
impression on them I'm interested in
having an entrepreneur career as an
employee with this is my objective do
you think making a unique beauty resume
is a good approach thank you for
everything Evan you're helping me be
more effective cool super honored I'm
happy that I'm helping you out man um I
think here's what I would do if I was
trying to get a job with a company
I would do two things I would one trust
and respect in their hiring process and
then to try to over-deliver and so a lot
of companies well every company has a
hiring process unless you're working
with a pure start but they don't know
what they're doing every company has a
hiring process that they go through and
if you don't follow that process then
it's unlikely you're going to get called
in right if you have to write a cover
letter and you don't write a cover
letter and you just submit a video it's
unlikely that they're going to call you
back because you didn't pass what they
asked you to do right people want to
hire creative thinkers and innovators
but they also want somebody who can work
within their system and so I would do my
best at giving them what they wanted so
cover letter you know answering their
questionnaire the resume whatever they
wanted to do and I would try to make
myself stand out as much as possible
using the traditional methods and then I
would do something over the top to get
notice to me oh that's the guy who did
the video submission as well right I
would try to research that company as
much as possible I would try to have
suggestions for how that business could
improve I would have done extra homework
reading articles about them and just
really doing my homework and really
trying to be creative and coming up with
potential solutions for them and if you
have a video that you know you feel
comfortable front of the camera and you
want to talk about your experiences and
share some of your ideas that's great I
would try to support them on social I
would try to respond to haters who are
who are hitting them up if they had a
video or a you know Twitter post or
Facebook post I would apply to them I
would support them I would try to do as
much as possible try to get on their
radar and be a valuable asset but I
would do it on top of the initial scope
of doing what they wanted so do both but
give them what they want and then go
above and beyond to really stand out and
wow them I think that's it thanks guys I
appreciate the love the support all the
questions I'd love to know your thoughts
on recording your processes that we
talked about in the book in this book
videos are at the top and if you have
questions about the book writing process
my book your book let me know in the
comments below and i will make a video
reply for you in next week's video thank
you guys much love from San Francisco
and I will see you soon